what what are you afraid of so because
for me
uh certain words have evolved the
meaning of certain words have evolved
for me over the years okay it's the
meaning of
love didn't mean the same to me at 10
and 20 then 30 then 40 than today with
four kids the meaning of competition was
very different in my teens and 20s and
30s and 40s than today the meaning of
fear fear for me recently has been very
different it's been a very different
meaning of fear
uh uh because fear to me it's been more
from the perspective of
i ask myself why why in certain things
that i'm doing like why why do you not
stop what is the fear that makes you not
stop the biggest fear i had was the fear
of my kids dying without them one with
my dad dying without my kids ever
meeting my dad like because i never met
his dad so that fear drove the hell out
of me right so i wanted to understand
the relationship with fear what was one
of your biggest fears like did you you
know how you go to sleep and there's
that one nightmare that you replay in
your milo dude this cannot happen what
fear haunted you the most
the fear changed over the year
when i was young
and i wanted to become champion it was
the fear of being humiliated you know
what i mean that was the fear and that's
pretty much the fear that i had for
the most part of my career you know to
be humiliated
then it changed to the fear of
maybe at one point because you become
more aware of
of of of what can happen you become
smarter and it's not necessarily a good
thing when you're a fighter to not to be
smart but
i'll try to explain the best as i can is
you realize that man i've been doing
this for a long time you don't know the
consequences of of brain damage in long
terms and you know in my fights i have
generally
always come come on top or at almost all
the time and i don't get punched too
much but in practice you know you have
to go through people always
say oh
your fight or you go you beat your
opponent pretty good without taking so
much damage it's true but in practice
you practice every day that's what you
know to get hit on the head every day
the impact the stress
the stress i think it's it's one of the
things that we don't talk about it's
crazy you're on fighter's flight you
know like drive a a little stress it it
helps you improve but to be on that
crazy fear stress of of of protection
that that is like a fighter's fight that
you always have someone that that you
know in a in a few weeks that you're
gonna fight that might kill you and
after that person once you beat him
there's another one and another one and
another one
so you constantly feel threatened
threatening
and for me i was obsessed is one of the
thing that helped me perform better is i
was obsessed by the idea of of being the
best
i was obsessed and being a champion
being a fighter it's a very selfish life
because everything is oriented towards
you me me me me how i can get better if
i do this is it going to help me improve
i was com i was completely insane
everything i i was doing at the time was
to get me a better fighter
and my perspectives change
because now i'm thinking about the
future like i don't want to do this
anymore i want to be i'm healthy you
know what i mean how old were you when
you started thinking that
i was a teenager i was a teenager when i
first saw royce gracie i knew that's
what i wanted to do for a living and
immediately my life shifted you know i
never been diagnosed
but i i think i'm a little bit of uh
obsessive compulsive
ocd yeah ocd i'm not the kind of guy who
can open the door ten times you know but
i have these things for example
um
the other
give you some example like how the brain
works and i think it's a good thing when
you're an athlete but in society could
be a bad thing
for example now i try to detach myself
from that but it's hard sometimes like
i'm driving my car
and i tell myself and i tell myself i'm
gonna hold my breath for uh
500 meter
and i at
four
four 450 meter i hit traffic
i'm like i'm holding my breath
i'm like [ __ ] i'm going on the side and
yeah i do with the extra 50 meter and
now i can write this is not normal man
this is not normal because you're
playing a game with yourself you're
playing a game with yourself i'm playing
my game but it's stupid but [ __ ] like
this i do but but now i still or the
other day i i go to um my cousin i go
pick up my cousin in at school
i'm opening the door for the parent that
comes out with their kids and i'm
holding the door and there is a kid that
that that comes and doesn't go through
he hold the door for me he goes go sir
and i'm like no no you go kid you go kid
now he's like no sir i'm like i'm
thinking saying
if i would have been younger i was like
hell no i'm not [ __ ] moving until you
go first but he's like yeah and i'm
thinking i'm saying
and it it it was hard for me to go
or no no i i went first and i lost but i
was like
this is not normal but think my brain
works like that yeah so you had like a
russian standoff with uh yeah when a kid
is like like eight years old like i'm
holding the door and he's holding door
is that your girlfriend no no please go
first and it's that was there was like
that was like okay thank you and i
played like play like nothing ever but
in my mind i was like
if that eight kid eight-year-old kid
only knew he's like by the way have you
ever seen a movie uh prefontaine you
ever seen the pre-fountain
the marathon the marathon run that would
run like three milers not one mile he
was like his coaches like you're better
at three the whole field night story
with the shoes
so there's a scene in the movie where
he's telling these kids so here you guys
can run with me and you're gonna
practice and all this stuff and he's at
this high school and he's an adult at
this point he's a champion everybody
knows and he's running and this one kid
keeps trying to get ahead of him and he
says no slow down you can't run ahead of
me he says the kid is 12 years old this
guy's 30 years i said he keeps running
he keeps trying to you can't get ahead
of me you have to stand behind
he says what is the and by the way
psychologically
he did not want to buy in the fact that
even anybody that could beat him so they
run at the end he still tells the kid
you can't run ahead of me so he keeps
running faster than him
these are the little quirks of the goats
that it's so hard to explain that
somebody will write a book and we'll
call you you know hypomanic you're
mentally awful
yeah but the world admires seeing folks
who are able to take the game to the
levels that you took it to i see it like
a little bit like a
like an addiction sort of it's something
that i needed in the past in order to
perform in my field of work
but now i
have to let go of these things and it's
very hard to let go man like
there's little things like that that
happened to me
and people don't notice it because i it
happened inside of my head but it's hard
man like like
like my some of my friend knows and they
play trick with me sometimes they like
like i'm eating sometime and sometimes i
notice i like everything lined up in my
in my table
and my friend
like let's say i go to bedroom when i
come back they they
they are
these are good friends the configuration
of the table and they they all laughing
it so when i come i automatically put it
up yeah and they're all like
you know like stuff like that i mean
it's funny but
that's the the thing i think it's part
of my
of my
of my
duty now to try to try to let go why
though why
do i have to because if i don't i will
be able to function and like my life has
changed now it's not about becoming the
best fighter in the world like i have to
to to blend in with the other people you
know what i mean otherwise it could be
dimensionable but you're you're only 40
40 years old i mean you still got 60
more years to live i agree but i think
it will not happen overnight i need to i
need to slowly adapt to this and i need
to release release i won't be able to
release everything from a to z i think
it will take time so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]
you